[Music]
hey everyone welcome to another
installment of harry potter theory in
today's video we're going to be
discussing mute commander magical
fantastic beasts and his trusty suitcase
more specifically we're going to be
diving into one very big question
how does newt scamander's suitcase work
and just how big are the environments
within it let's jump in now just last
week i was re-watching fantastic beasts
one and two prepping myself and to
making sure that i was on top of all the
details of the prequel films in advance
of the release of the third installment
coming april 15th fantastic beasts the
secrets of dumbledore
the films which i've seen just a few
times at this point a stark difference
between the number of times i've seen
the harry potter films probably hundreds
there were more or less just as i had
remembered however there was one
lingering question in the back of my
mind just how on earth does newt
scamander's suitcase work and more
importantly just how many magical
creatures are housed within it which
creatures can be found inside we're
first introduced to newt scamander in
the new fantastic beasts films and
though much a fantastic beast takes
place in the u.s so far newt is actually
originally from the uk and this of
course means that he attended hogwarts
in his later life newt became a famed
magi zoologist and authored fantastic
beasts and where to find them a book
which outlines the study of magical
creatures i have visited lairs burrows
and nests across five continents
observed the curious habits of magical
beasts in a hundred countries witnessed
their powers gained their trust and on
occasion beaten them off with my
travelling kettle newt's profession
requires him to intensely study all
manners of creatures and sometimes this
involves relocating them or simply
preserving them in order to ensure that
they don't go extinct this makes newt's
suitcase even more important
now i'm more than aware of the fact that
the harry potter universe is filled with
magic we've seen people splitting their
soul apart transforming into different
animals reading people's minds and even
producing giant fiery dragons out of the
tip of their ones we've even seen people
time travel but when i first saw the
capabilities of newt scamander's
suitcase a presumably 30 inch by 18 inch
rectangular piece of luggage housing
what appears to be an entire other world
i was awestruck
i don't know about you guys but to me
this level of magic seems like it's on
another level and though witches and
wizards within harry potter were
impressed with newt suitcase none seemed
to be too taken aback this got me
thinking just how does newt's magical
suitcase work is this simple magic or
magic too complicated for most to
comprehend
well as it turns out similar magic has
been used in harry potter before if you
think back you may recall that arthur
weasley placed a similar spell on the
flying ford anglia allowing the small
car to accommodate all the weasleys and
their luggage other notable instances
include mundungus fletcher casting this
same spell on a car in 1995 and hermione
placing this spell on her handbag before
going off and hunting horcruxes
well it's no coincidence that these
spells displayed similar properties as
these are in fact examples of the same
spell that newt used a little spell
known as the extension charm or
undetectable extension charm however
what i really want to highlight here is
that newts was on an entirely different
level
extension charms are widely considered
to be a very sophisticated branch of
magic that allow witches and wizards to
manipulate space the charm essentially
expands an object's internal dimensions
while retaining its external appearance
all while reducing the total weight in
fact extension charms are considered to
be such an advanced form of magic that
they are subject to strict control
through the ministry of magic mainly due
to the spell's potential to breach the
international statute of secrecy there
was even a law put in place that forbade
private use with permissible use
reserved for objects that had been
individually approved for manufacture
what newt possessed with his suitcase
was perhaps the most extreme example of
the charm's power in existence as it
housed entire ecosystems for the magical
beasts who lived within with our present
level of knowledge we know there to be
15 different magical habitats within
ut's suitcase housing 23 different
magical creatures if you thought
hermione's handbag was impressive then
you should now realize just how
impressive nude suitcase is speaking to
his ability as a wizard
also now that you know how newt suitcase
works let's dive into the ecosystems
inside what are these 15 different
habitats what are these creatures let's
dive in further starting things off
let's take a look at in no particular
order the 15 habitats that newt created
in order to accommodate his magical
beasts later we'll look at the creatures
these different habitats were created
via atmospheric charms within the
magical chest
charms upon charms 15. a rumpant habitat
the erumpent habitat resembles a
grassland intended to be reminiscent of
the african savannah this environment
was dry with pale grass and wide-brimmed
trees which offered shade from the sun
14. floating tree habitat
this habitat contains a small floating
piece of earth covered in golden leaves
and a cluster of small trees sprouting
upwards this habitat was positioned just
below the bamboo forest
number 13 nundu habitat this habitat is
a rainforest containing many trees and a
large rocky outcrop
this habitat leads into the mooncalf
habitats
12. mooncalf habitat similar to the
noondoo habitat the mooncalf habitat is
a small rocky mountain with grass and
trees that grow on it 11. thunderbird
habitat the thunderbird habitat contains
a large rock formation surrounded by
desert and is intended to be reminiscent
of the deserts of arizona 10. grindelow
habitat the grindelow habitat contained
a large square of water that the
grindeloes inhabited the creatures were
able to float around outside of the
water in large bubbles of water
9. bamboo forest habitat the bamboo
forest habitat contained tall trees
which supported nests for bird-like
creatures
just outside of the tool bamboo lay a
series of stone constructions likely
home to giant dung beetles 8. zuwu
habitat newt created a habitat for the
zoo after rescuing it from the streets
of paris this habitat appeared to be
quite similar to the aforementioned
bamboo forest habitat however there is
always the possibility that newt simply
expanded the existing habitat to
accommodate the large zoo
7. light bulb habitat the light bulb
habitat floats high above the other
environments and it's here that newt
keeps several empty light bulbs where
young glow worms reside
6. chinese pagoda this habitat which at
first glance resembles a miniature
chinese pagoda transforms into a
magically expanded cave upon entry
likely using a charm much like the
suitcase's own
5. earthen habitat this habitat
possessed a large floating earthen area
with a thick tree on top roots hung down
from underneath which touched the floor
this area overlooked the floating tree
habitat the bamboo forest and nude shed
4. grapporn habitat this habitat was a
flat grey area that led into a tall rock
formation
this habitat was positioned behind the
bamboo forest and nuke shed just outside
of this habitat was a perch for a fupa
3. snowy habitat this blank snowy
habitat was home to a floating obscurus
this habitat was supposed to be hard to
discover as it was contained by large
curtains it's possible that other
creatures lived in this habitat although
newt may have wanted to keep the
obscurus on its own
2. water habitat in fantastic beasts the
crimes of grindelwald we see newt diving
into the water and tending to the kelpie
he dives in closer to his living area
and resurfaces in a habitat that
resembles a scottish lock presumably
this environment is for all water-based
beasts 1. frozen habitat in the films
newt keeps a frozen ashwinder egg so
it's possible there is some kind of a
frozen environment within his suitcase
it's always possible that this egg could
have lived in the snowy habitat but i
don't suspect that newt would have
placed any other creatures near the
obscurus and that's about it for the
habitats at least the ones that we know
about so far
it's amazing what news been able to
produce placing extension charms upon
extension charms upon atmospheric charms
now let's get into the creatures that we
know to live in nude suitcase
some of them were dead giveaways by the
habitat names one augury's the augury
also known as the irish phoenix was a
thin and mournful looking magical bird
somewhat like a small underfed vulture
in appearance with greenish black
feathers and a sharp beak
2. billywigs the billywig was a magical
insect native to australia it was rated
triple x and was around half an inch
long and of vivid sapphire blue color
the speed of the billy wig may be why it
was rarely noticed by muggles and
wizards and witches often only spotted
it once they had been stung 3.
bowtruckles the bowtruckle was a
hand-sized insect-eating tree-dwelling
magical beast with long sharp fingers
two on each hand
brown eyes and a general appearance of a
flat-faced stick figure made out of bark
and twigs which served well as
camouflage in its natural habitat for
demiguise the demiguise was a peaceful
herbivorous magical beast that could
make itself invisible and to tell the
future which made it very hard to catch
5. doxies the doxie sometimes referred
to as the biting fairy was a small
very-like magical beast sometimes
mistaken for a fairy the doxie was
covered in coarse black hair and had an
additional set of arms and legs doxies
had shiny beetle-like wings and a double
row of sharp teeth
6. dear recall the direcol known to
muggles as the dodo was a plump fluffy
feathered and flightless magical bird
native to the island of mauritius in the
indian ocean while muggles believed this
bird to be extinct in reality it existed
and had the ability to disappear and
reappear elsewhere as a means of
escaping danger similar to apparition 7.
a rumpant the rumpant is a large grey
african beast of great power weighing up
to a ton the erumpent may be mistaken
for a rhinoceros at a distance it has a
thick hind that repels most charms and
curses a large sharp horn upon its nose
and a long rope-like tail
8. fupa the fupa was a magical african
bird with brightly coloured feathers
which could include orange pink lime
green and yellow
listening to the frupa's high-pitched
twittering song would drive the listener
insane
9. giant dung beetles the giant dung
beetle was a large magical insect it is
mostly unknown how it was different from
its non-magical cousin however it was
significantly larger and could use the
three large horns on its head to carry
balls of dung instead of rolling them an
action which it could still perform
10. glow bugs glow bugs were small
luminescent magical worms 11. grap horns
the grap horn is found in mountainous
european regions large and grayish
purple with a humped back the grap horn
has two very long sharp horns walks on
large four-thumbed feet and has an
extremely aggressive nature
12. grindelow's a grindelobe is a small
horned pale green-skinned water demon
native to great britain and ireland
13. lucrota the lucrota resembled a
large moose with very long jagged
antlers and an impossibly huge mouth in
respect to its head and face it was
capable of stretching its jaws wide
enough that a full-grown human could fit
inside 14. marmite the name of this one
is hilarious the marmite was a
moderate-sized squid-like magical beast
described as a cross between a dust mite
and squid it has a transparent
bioluminescent body and long trailing
tentacles 15. moon carves the moon calf
was a shy magical beast that only came
out of its burrow during a full moon
the moon calf had smooth pale grey skin
and four spindly legs that ended in
large flat webbed feet the moon calf
also had a very long neck and bulging
blue eyes that sat on the top of its
head
16. mertlapse the mertlap was a magical
marine beast resembling a rat with a
growth on its back resembling a sea
enemy found on the coastal areas of
britain 17. niffler the niffler was a
magical beast with a long snout and a
coat of black fluffy fur they were
attracted to shiny things which made
them wonderful for locating treasure but
that also meant that they could wreak
havoc if camped or let loose indoors 18.
noondoo the noondoo was a large east
african magical beast that resembled a
leopard it moved silently despite its
gigantic size and was considered by some
to be the most dangerous creature alive
19. occamis the occamy is found in the
far east and india a plumed two-legged
winged creature with a serpentine body
it feeds mainly on rats and birds though
has been known to carry off monkeys the
occamy is aggressive to all who approach
it particularly in defense of its eggs
20. rune spores the rune spore was a
magical three-headed snake native to the
african country of burkina faso
rune spores were commonly six to seven
feet long an exception being the one
held by newt scamander that was gigantic
in size with orange and black stripes
21. swooping evil the swooping evil was
a blue and green winged dark magical
beast it appeared similar to an
extremely large butterfly but with a
wolf-like skull in place of an ordinary
head when it was not flying with its
spiked wings the swooping evil shrunk
into a green spiny cocoon
22. thunderbird the thunderbird was a
large magical avian beast native to
north america and most commonly found in
arizona in the southwestern united
states a close relative of the phoenix
the thunderbird could create storms as
it flew and was highly sensitive to
danger
23. zuwu the zuwu was a powerful magical
beast native to china it was a
monstrously large feline-like beast with
a striped body scraggly mane four fangs
that curled out of its mouth long sharp
claws and a disproportionately long
ruffled multi-coloured tail and that's
it for this video i hope you learned a
little bit about newt's case how it
works what's inside and what creatures
you can find within
if you enjoy the content please be sure
to like the video and subscribe to the
channel
until next time remember
it does not do to dwell on dreams and
forget to live